wer gewinnt die amerikanische wal und
vor allem warum bitte um kurze antwort
und professor strikt was glauben sie wer
gewinnt die us wahl und warum mit der
frage habe ich jetzt nicht gerechnet das
ist auf jeden fall keine medizinische
frage aber ich kann mir gut vorstellen
dass trump die wahl gewinnen wird weil
ersten großen rückhalt haben schon und
noch eine medizinische frage an sie
nachgereicht professor street glauben
sie dass sonntagmorgen wieder mobile
office sitzt
das ist schwer zu sagen also das ja rein
spekulativ die ärzte haben gesagt er
würde in oberhof sitzen aber medizinisch
ist wahrscheinlich besser wenn auch sich
noch mehr ausprobieren würde aber aus
der ferne über diese meinung über den
ozean ist es wirklich schwer zu sagen